the Arab world is sitting on a powder
keg says hadiza ha Muji a third of young
people in the region are out of work and
that figure set to rise having traveled
widely in Egypt and beyond she's spoken
to many of them by 2020 over 100 million
young people are going to enter in the
job market over a hundred million young
people that's a huge freaking number
Khadija hmoo tease parents are from
Morocco she was born in Belgium and has
lived in London and Berlin at the moment
he's in San Francisco where she's
working in a startup incubator very one
fair but it's just a room and was not
fair to be outside them our aim is to
produce an app that provides information
in Arabic on how to set up a business
team helping to kick-start fledgling
enterprises in the region what I call
chief human development officers she
believes there's a gap in the market for
business knowledge of this kind are two
different segments when you speak about
education young people people say oh is
it a program to deride utilize youth
there is that still strong prejudicial
assumption that people think everyone
because they are Arabs / Muslims or at
risk of becoming terrorists as if 375
million young people were ready to be
radicalized simply because there are
Arabs Khadija hmoo geez lucky she's had
the chance to visit startup workshops
make contacts and try things out many
young people in the Arab world don't
have that privilege those who do go to
university often seek secure jobs as
civil servants or in big corporations
few dare to go it alone a lot of
distance value proposition she's
financing her venture with crowdfunding
as well as her own savings the otra
preneur ship is a very very lonely
pathway definitely solitude sometimes
also stability the fact that I moved
from place to place to be able to carry
out the project is great because people
see the commitment but sometimes I just
wished I was going into I could give an
address the same address people to both
letters to the 26 year old gave up her
job as a teacher in London to follow her
dream but there's little time to enjoy
San Francisco she's working 12 to 16
hour days yeah her meeting with her
software developer in Dubai isn't
scheduled until tenant nice UAE is 12
hours ahead the whole morale bardelli
sirenita steady dr. Maha Facebook touche
tohmatsu I was right there perfect yeah
as well as programming the apps
prototype Diana a boot also gives
Khadijah advice know a lot of the use
they don't know how to find this content
there is not a lot of content that they
would find online so it's they also need
some kind of guidance and when they find
other people or a platform that kind of
brings all these communities that want
to learn together so they kind of
connect together and they will like
empower each other one that the Arab
Spring show just how quickly young
people were able to mobilize via the
Internet they know what they want they
know they want something different they
know they want a better quality
education system they know that they
want a better healthcare system they
know what they deserve they know what
they deserve and they're going to ask
for it to help keep herself going she
thinks of the words of her favorite poet
start walking towards the Sun your legs
will get heavy and tired then comes a
moment of feeling the wings with you've
grown lifting roomy and Arab poets an
Arab Sufi poet Khadijah hmoo G is
already planning her next trip she wants
to tour nine Arabic on trees testing
whether her up really works for young
people there
[Music]